demi-tour droite
les rudiments de l'art de la guerre
et vous mettez bien les chevilles
collées au sol
pour les encadrer
il y a quelques jours de Caroline du Sud
ou encore de Californie comme William
n'oublie pas
pour la liberté
je suis là pour les aider comme je peux
américain anglais israélien est dans
quelques jours des Français ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à venir des quatre
coins du monde pour rejoindre la Légion
géorgienne quand je vous dis deux vous
vous mettez exactement dans cette
position
aujourd'hui en formation demain
peut-être sur la ligne de front avec
leur volontaire étrangers
le lendemain William le Californien
explique comment démonter une
kalachnikov
dis-lui juste que c'est super direction
ensuite le pas de tir Léna est étudiante
en droit
artiste ouvrier ou comptable comme cette
femme
avec tous une immense motivation vous
êtes contente du résultat non je voulais
mettre la balle dans le mille
les Géorgiens ont combattu les Russes en
2008 aujourd'hui ils aident les civils
Ukrainiens à se préparer au pire
j'ai jamais vu des gens comme ça les
civils Ukrainiens n'ont même pas peur de
la guerre
au combat rapproché ou encore de
premiers secours sur une ligne de front
l'objectif formé 3000 civils avec cette
formation express de 3 jours seulement